let's go next to jim from chattanooga
jim welcome
hi david uh long time uh viewer how are
you doing doing well
uh i guess my question is how to reframe
uh kind of basically the basic idea is
there's gonna be pain and i think
democrats are struggling with this um
basically a lot of the problems are
right now that we're suffering from are
from taking the can down the road
and a lot of the solutions tend to have
short-term sacrifice involved how do we
reframe that so people that are in their
60s who will never enjoy
a working universal healthcare system
are willing to make that sacrifice
well this isn't really like a new thing
that humans do i mean i think for most
humans with a normal
uh
emotional
landscape the idea that we might do
something that's good for the species we
belong to even if i won't personally
benefit from it
is still a completely reasonable thing
to do i mean you know the interstate
highway system took a very long time to
build and many of the people that
supported their tax dollars going to it
didn't live long enough to enjoy it and
i i mean it's right it doesn't seem i
think the weird thing to me isn't
why the weird thing to me would be that
more people wouldn't of course
understand that the way things are the
way the some of the good things we have
today we have because people who didn't
benefit from them were okay supporting
them financially and that as a result we
should do the same thing to keep
improving society it would be
if we have to explain that to people
then we're in real trouble
so you don't think the attitude around
that has changed i think that it hasn't
changed in terms of
people's emotional understanding of it
but i do think that the the political
system we have
including these terms of two four and
six years that don't really encourage
long-term thinking they encourage what
can i do to justify my next re-election
that definitely is not good
right and i think that's just a
feature yes
yeah absolutely
thank you david all right thank you
maybe just one more thing i'm getting a
vasectomy next week and i thought maybe
you could
comment on that i'm 36 no kids hmm
that's interesting you know most many
many urologists won't do a no kids
vasectomy for people your age how what
was the conversation like
well i found one in georgia so i'll be
traveling oh so you're admitting it was
hard to find one you have you had to go
to find up one in a different place
not just find one they would find one
that's affordable like under two
thousand dollars it's not just it
if you don't have money you can't just
go i don't know people think that these
things are just out there to go grab the
off the shelf somewhere but did you talk
to urologists who said you know for
someone in your situation i don't really
do vasectomies you don't have kids
you're only 36
i honestly didn't even look here in
tennessee because i didn't want to deal
with it oh okay
all right good well so why are you doing
you're just very sure you never want to
have kids
well and i live in tennessee i mean
i don't want to be forced into
fatherhood sorry i just don't
okay what do you mean by that
well i think we had a tracker law here
so when roe was overturned i think it's
six weeks now it might be six weeks but
it may oh i see what you're trying to do
any thought to maybe freezing sperm so
you have the option
ah
no there's probably there's probably a
little couple little jimmies floating
out there somewhere they can you know
i'm just kidding david i'm just kidding
no i haven't considered that okay all
right very good jim thank you good luck
with the procedure
love you david all right thank you i
love you buddy okay we're gonna take a
quick break if you're holding don't hang
up we are going back to the phones on
what has been an eventful day an
eventful day standby right back to the
phones in a moment